bine ai revenit la Quantum Computing în practică, eu sunt gazda ta, Olivia Lanes, data trecută am parcurs un exemplu de
abordare de Quantum Computing pentru o problemă de optimizare cunoscută sub numele de Max Cut, folosind formularea Cubo, am mers
destul de în profunzime, dar acesta a fost doar un exemplu al unei singure abordări, astăzi vom discuta aplicațiile pe termen scurt
mai general și vom dezvolta intuiția noastră pentru diferite tipuri de probleme pentru care ne așteptăm să găsim soluții Quantum utile
și vom vedea câteva exemple recente de lucrări importante realizate în comunitatea noastră la o scară de utilitate
anterior am discutat pe scurt că nu toate problemele au nevoie de putere de calcul suplimentară
în mod specific Quantum Computing pentru a fi rezolvate eficient acestea sunt problemele cu care ești deja cel mai
familiarizat: aritmetică, derulat pe rețele sociale, poate jucând Tetris, Doom sau alte jocuri video, le considerăm în general
probleme ușoare, pe de altă parte există probleme foarte dificile, cum ar fi găsirea factorilor primi ai unor numere
întregi enorme, și aceasta este baza criptării RSA și ceea ce algoritmul lui Shor a fost de fapt conceput să rezolve, un alt
exemplu este găsirea unei soluții într-un set de date nesortat, teoretic aceasta poate fi rezolvată de algoritmul cuantic cunoscut
sub numele de algoritmul lui Grover, totuși majoritatea experților sunt de acord că aceste tipuri de algoritmi vor necesita
implementarea corecției erorilor și nu am ajuns încă acolo din punct de vedere tehnologic, deci pe măsură ce avansăm în această
lecție și în parcursul tău educațional Quantum, amintește-ți că suntem în căutarea acestui punct optim undeva aici la mijloc
este o problemă grea de rezolvat, dar asta o face și atât de interesantă, un lucru pe care nu l-am discutat încă
prea mult este teoria complexității computaționale, unul dintre motive este că poate fi oarecum intimidantă, și da
complexă, teoria complexității computaționale este domeniul informaticii care urmărește să clasifice problemele computaționale
în funcție de dificultatea lor, există o tonă de clase de complexitate diferite în calculul clasic, dar cele mai
fundamentale sunt aceste probleme P, acestea sunt probleme care pot fi rezolvate în timp polinomial pe măsură ce
dimensiunea problemei crește, ceea ce înseamnă că sunt ușor de rezolvat, următorul tip de problemă mai dificilă este problemele NP care
înseamnă polinomial nedeterminist, acestea sunt probleme ale căror răspunsuri pot fi verificate în timp polinomial, dar nu
neapărat rezolvate, urmează NP complet și acum intrăm în problemele cu adevărat provocatoare fără
nicio soluție polinomială cunoscută, acesta este locul unde trăiesc probleme celebre precum problema comisului voiajor și chiar jocul
Sudoku, acum când Quantum Computing a apărut, cel puțin în teorie, oamenii au depus eforturi considerabile încercând să
înțeleagă ce clasă de probleme ar putea rezolva eficient aceste noi tipuri de calculatoare, o nouă clasă de
probleme a fost inventată numită probleme polinomiale cuantice cu eroare mărginită sau bqp pe scurt, definiția lor strictă este
puțin lungă, dar este clasa de probleme de decizie rezolvabile de un calculator cuantic în timp polinomial cu o mică
șansă de eroare, există o șansă de eroare deoarece măsurarea cuantică este în mod inerent aleatoare, dar eroarea
probabilitate poate fi arbitrar de mică, acum toate aceste clase trăiesc într-o clasă mai mare pe care o numim pspace și acesta este locul unde
credem că bqp se situează relativ la toate celelalte tipuri de probleme, dar este foarte greu de dovedit definitiv acest lucru
matematic, vei observa că problemele Quantum bqp nu se suprapun neapărat cu problemele NP complet
totuși s-ar putea să fi văzut unele abordări de Quantum Computing care vizează rezolvarea problemelor NP complet, de ce ar fi
cazul? o concepție greșită comună este că nu are sens să explorezi soluții
la probleme precum problema comisului voiajor și alte probleme NP complet pentru un calculator cuantic sau orice problemă pentru care o
dovadă matematică a accelerării cuantice nu a fost găsită, totuși acest lucru nu trebuie neapărat să fie cazul
găsirea dovezii matematice că un algoritm Quantum este mai rapid decât echivalentul său clasic este rară, Shor și
Grover sunt două dintre puținele exemple în care acest lucru a fost realizat până acum, dar asta este bine, de fapt informaticienii
tot nu au reușit să dovedească că clasele P și NP sunt diferite, chiar dacă toată intuiția
ne spune că trebuie să fie, de asemenea compararea a doi algoritmi și a modului în care se scalează privește adesea scenariul cel mai defavorabil
pentru fiecare, este destul de posibil ca în practică scenariul cel mai defavorabil să nu fie cel pe care îl găsim în viața reală, deci
nu disperăm, introducem în schimb ideea soluțiilor euristice, dacă ești un
experimentalist deja cunoști și iubești aceste tipuri de soluții, o euristică este orice abordare pentru rezolvarea unei
probleme care este pragmatică dar nu neapărat optimă, și asta e grozav deoarece soluțiile nu trebuie neapărat
să fie optime pentru a fi foarte utile, de exemplu gândește-te la o aplicație financiară, nu am găsit încă o
accelerare exponențială pentru majoritatea algoritmilor financiari pentru care Quantum ar putea fi utilizat, dar asta nu contează neapărat, nu avem nevoie de o soluție optimă
în finanțe cel puțin, pentru că o soluție care este chiar și cu doar 1% mai eficientă ar putea echivala cu miliarde de dolari
în profit, deci cum știm ce cazuri de utilizare și probleme ar putea fi potrivite pentru Quantum Computing chiar acum, și prin asta
mă refer că există motive semnificative să credem că utilitatea Quantum sau chiar Avantajul ar putea fi găsite fie acum, fie
în viitorul relativ apropiat, poate că este mai ușor să numim mai întâi lucrurile pe care problema cu siguranță nu ar trebui să le aibă
nu poate necesita un număr enorm de qubiți, nu avem încă procesoare cu mii până la milioane de qubiți disponibili, acesta este unul dintre principalele motive
pentru care algoritmul lui Shor și altele similare sunt atât de departe, circuit-urile de asemenea nu pot fi incredibil de adânci, îmi este cu adevărat greu
să îți spun exact ce adâncime de circuit nu va funcționa, deoarece depinde de atât de mulți factori, dar în general dacă
experimentul tău necesită o adâncime pe care nu ai văzut-o atinsă în literatură, s-ar putea să ai parte de o perioadă dificilă și
în ultimul rând orice tip de algoritm despre care știm că va necesita corecție a erorilor nu poate fi realizat încă, ce ar trebui să căutăm însă sunt experimente care
utilizează majoritatea qubiților disponibili pe orice qpu dat, am subliniat de asemenea
importanța atenuării și suprimării erorilor și în ultimul rând ar trebui să existe o extindere evidentă către viitoarele
aplicații care ar fi importante pentru societate și pe care le-am putea vedea eventual ducând la Quantum
Advantage, acum să vorbim despre câteva exemple de cazuri de utilizare care se încadrează în trei categorii principale pe care le-am
identificat ca fiind cele mai susceptibile să vadă rezultate favorabile pe termen scurt până la mediu
primul domeniu este simularea naturii, am vorbit despre asta anterior, există
atât de multe oportunități pentru calculatoarele cuantice de a îmbunătăți cercetarea realizată la nivel molecular și atomic
WEBVTT
și motivul pentru aceasta este că metodele clasice actuale sunt limitate de descrieri matematice fundamental ineficiente
ale structurilor atomice, stocarea și manipularea unei stări cuantice necesită o cantitate exponențială de resurse
pe un calculator clasic, dar poate fi realizată eficient pe un calculator cuantic, și asta face ca simularea materialelor
și modelarea chimică să fie unele dintre cele mai promițătoare domenii de aplicare, mai specific, aceasta ar putea duce la
dezvoltări în captarea dioxidului de carbon, baterii alternative sau inventarea de noi medicamente, câțiva
algoritmi deosebit de relevanți în acest domeniu sunt variational quantum eigensolver vqe, care este utilizat pentru
estimarea anumitor proprietăți ale unui material, cum ar fi stările de echilibru sau de energie minimă, un alt exemplu este
simularea dinamicii temporale TDS, acel algoritm este utilizat pentru estimarea funcțiilor de răspuns sau a proprietăților spectrale ale
materialelor și am vrut să menționez și un nou venit, diagonalizarea cuantică bazată pe eșantioane, despre care credem că vom
auzi mult mai mult în viitorul apropiat, următorul domeniu de aplicare este optimizarea, optimizarea este destul de
omniprezentă în calculul informatic după cum îți poți imagina, deci cazurile de utilizare sunt destul de numeroase și variate
totuși câteva exemple despre care auzim mult sunt optimizarea portofoliului în finanțe, designul industrial și, de asemenea,
distribuția și lanțul de aprovizionare, cel mai comun algoritm despre care vei auzi probabil legat de optimizare este cel pe care
l-am acoperit deja în profunzime, algoritmul de optimizare aproximativă cuantică sau
qaoa, în ultimul rând, un domeniu care a generat multă entuziasm în ultimii câțiva ani este quantum machine learning, acum
cred că este corect să spunem că se pare că qml nu va apărea la fel de curând ca simularea în toate probabilitățile, dar cu toate acestea există
câțiva algoritmi impresionanți la care oamenii lucrează constant, corespunzând unor cazuri de utilizare foarte importante
unele dintre aceste posibile cazuri de utilizare sunt procesarea limbajului natural, analiza traficului de rețea și chiar detectarea
fraudelor în tranzacțiile financiare, algoritmii relevanți în acest domeniu sunt quantum support vector
machine, rețelele neuronale cuantice și rețelele generative adversariale cuantice, acum pentru a clarifica, acele trei
grupuri pe care tocmai le-am descris sunt domenii largi de aplicare, merită de asemenea menționat că în comunitate există
și beneficii pentru grupurile care lucrează împreună și care sunt focalizate pe un subiect specific, IBM a condus o inițiativă nu cu mult timp în urmă
numită Grupurile de Lucru pentru a ajuta colaboratorii să se întâlnească și să creeze sinergii productive în patru domenii specifice
sănătate și științe ale vieții, materiale și HPC, fizica energiilor înalte și
optimizare, iată grupurile noastre actuale și entitățile implicate în acele eforturi, dacă vrei să auzi mai multe despre
ceea ce fac grupurile de lucru, am atașat patru din documentele lor albe în descrierea de mai jos, acum, așa cum am spus,
cred că cel mai bun lucru de făcut în acest moment al cursului este să petrecem ceva timp explorând ce tipuri de probleme lucrează oamenii pe
frontiera acestei tehnologii și să ne dezvoltăm intuiția pentru a știi ce tipuri de algoritmi vor funcționa și cum
să îi aplicăm, și înainte de a începe vreau doar să clarific că scopul principal nu este să înțelegem fiecare
detaliu al experimentelor, acest tip de analiză poate fi foarte intimidant chiar și pentru experți dacă lucrarea este puțin
în afara domeniului tău de expertiză, scopul este pur și simplu de a ajuta la dezvoltarea intuiției pentru tipurile de probleme pe care
calculatoarele cuantice le rezolvă bine și cum să le gestionezi, și dacă ești interesat de detaliile mai fine și dacă aceasta a aprins câteva
idei proprii, te încurajez cu siguranță să mergi și să citești lucrările complete, cazurile de utilizare specifice și
lucrările pe care le vom examina în profunzime sunt acestea, mai întâi vom explora o lucrare care discută
simularea dinamicii hadronilor, aceasta se încadrează în categoria fizicii energiilor înalte, în continuare vom analiza o problemă de optimizare
în mod specific optimizarea cuantică contra-adiabatica cu câmp de polarizare, și în ultimul rând vom analiza o altă
problemă de simulare, dar de data aceasta focalizată pe mRNA, o moleculă crucială pentru
dezvoltarea de medicamente și terapii, dacă ești familiarizat sau nu cu aceste lucrări, nu e o problemă, vom trece
prin toate, toate trei sunt lucrări importante care abordează probleme de dimensiuni substanțiale și arată cum
calculatoarele cuantice încep să fie folosite ca o altă metodă de cercetare științifică, primul este simularea dinamicii hadronilor
și vom analiza în profunzime o lucrare a grupului lui Martin Savage de la Universitatea din Washington, numită Quantum
simulations of hadron Dynamics in the schwinger model using 112
qubiți, dacă nu ești fizician al energiilor înalte, s-ar putea să fii totuși familiarizat cu termenul hadron, cum ar fi în
Large Hadron Collider sau LHC, care este uriașul accelerator de particule cu 27 de kilometri în circumferință, care a făcut posibil
să se observe în cele din urmă bosonul Higgs, un hadron este o particulă subatomică compusă formată din alte particule mici
numite quarci, câteva exemple ar fi neutronii și protonii, pentru un pic de context, LHC a fost construit
pentru a permite studierea fizicii fundamentale și a ceea ce se întâmplă cu particulele atunci când se ciocnesc la energii extrem de mari
în acest tub circular, făcând aceasta, oamenii de știință speră să afle mai multe despre cum a luat naștere Universul timpuriu
și, așa cum am spus anterior, a fost folosit și pentru a găsi bosonul, care este o particulă evazivă responsabilă de masa
particulelor fundamentale, acum în principiu interacțiunile acestor particule ar putea fi
simulate de la început până la sfârșit cu un calculator cuantic suficient de puternic, nu am ajuns chiar acolo, dar progresul
se face, modelul Schwinger este un model simplu folosit pentru a simula unele dintre aceste dinamici și a apărut ca unul dintre
cele mai populare modele alese, detaliile modelului nu sunt super importante pentru moment, dar pentru cei
curioși, este un model care descrie comportamentul electronilor și pozitronilor care interacționează prin fotoni în 1 + 1 D
dimensiuni, ceea ce înseamnă că există o dimensiune spațială și timp, modelul are multe similitudini cu
cromodinamica cuantică, care descrie cum interacționează quarcii și hadronii, acum aceasta este extrem de greu de simulat, deci
modelul Schwinger este adesea folosit ca model de jucărie pentru a investiga unele fenomene care sunt de fapt comune
ambelor, acum modul în care vom proceda cu acest exemplu și cu restul exemplelor pe care le-am selectat este
prin a ne pune o serie de întrebări, prima este de ce am avut motive să credem că simularea acestui lucru
pe un calculator cuantic va funcționa deloc, în acest caz electronii și pozitronii din modelul Schwinger au un efect de ecranare
cauzând corelații între fononi îndepărtați să scadă exponențial cu separarea, și aceasta înseamnă că există
WEBVTT
nu sunt atât de multe interacțiuni pe rază lungă de la un qubit pe o parte a chip-ului la altul pe cealaltă parte a chip-ului
ceea ce știm că este foarte predispus la erori, deci aceasta este cu adevărat bun pentru hardware-ul pe care îl avem disponibil astăzi, urmează
subiectul chiar este de interes? ei bine, sper că te-am convins deja că da, fizica energiilor înalte este de mare
interes, oamenii au fost dispuși să cheltuiască miliarde de dolari pentru a construi LHC și mii de oameni de știință și
tehnicieni din întreaga lume și-au dedicat viețile acestui domeniu, atât de importantă este, dar
modelul Schwinger este simplistic și nu este conceput să acopere trei dimensiuni spațiale, cu toate acestea este un
model important deoarece oferă în continuare secțiuni actualmente testabile și o simplificare utilă a unei teorii complete
în ultimul rând, cum a fost realizată această lucrare sau ce abordare ar folosi dacă ar dori să continue lucrarea în
experimente de tip simulare, vqe este una dintre cele mai comune abordări și primul pas este aproape întotdeauna același:
pregătirea stării fundamentale, în acest caz este o stare de vid, și în acest experiment folosesc o nouă versiune a vqe numită SC
adapt vqe pentru a pregăti atât starea fundamentală cât și pachetul de unde al hadronului deasupra vidului, pasul următor este
să lași hadronii să evolueze sau să se propage în timp, în ultimul rând trebuie să identificăm
observabilele pe care vrem să le detectăm, acum dacă acei pași ți s-au părut oarecum familiari, minus partea cu pachetul de unde al hadronului,
asta se datorează faptului că acești pași sunt foarte similari cu ceea ce am acoperit în exemplul qaoa din episodul anterior
sper că începi să observi câteva tipare care apar, componentele necesare pentru vqe sunt foarte similare cu qaoa,
începem dintr-o stare familiară, aici starea de vid, și apoi o lăsăm să evolueze în timp cu o serie de hamiltoniene exponențiate
împărțite în bucăți gestionabile unde n este numărul de diviziuni, singura mare diferență aici
este că creăm pachetul de unde al hadronului centrat în circuit-ul nostru înainte de a-l lăsa să evolueze, deci cum se
face asta? ei bine, starea de vid este starea fundamentală și am acoperit deja cumva cum să o mapăm, acum pregătirea pachetului de unde al hadronului
este puțin diferită, pe acest vid un hadron poate fi excitat prin crearea unei perechi fermion-antifermion pe
site-uri adiacente, prin pregătirea unei superpoziții a unor astfel de hadroni la locații diferite, un pachet de unde
arbitrar poate fi pregătit, autorii au centrat pachetul de unde în mijlocul circuit-ului pentru a observa evoluția
fără a depăși o limită, dar amintește-ți că regula jocului când lucrezi cu qpu-uri cu zgomot este să menții
adâncimea circuit-ului gestionabilă, pentru a face asta protocolul SC adapt vqe folosește simetria și
ierarhiile în scalele de lungime pentru a determina circuit-uri cuantice cu adâncime redusă pentru pregătirea stării, ideea este că aceasta
va crea un ansatz cu un număr mai mic de parametri echivalând cu o adâncime mai mică, mai multe detalii pot desigur
fi găsite în lucrare decât avem timp să acoperim aici, deci asigură-te că o verifici, acum să aruncăm o privire la rezultate, acest experiment a fost rulat pe
un dispozitiv IBM Quantum Heron și a implementat câteva tipuri diferite de atenuare și suprimare a erorilor
incluzând o tehnică mai recentă numită renormalizarea decoherenței operatorului, precum și decuplarea dinamică, extrapolarea zgomotului zero
și twirling polinomial, acum să încercăm să interpretăm datele, observabilul pe care de fapt îl vom
măsura pentru a observa cum se propagă pachetul de unde este ceva numit condensatul chiral, care este puțin
abstract, dar este în esență o fază superfluide a hadronilor, acum putem vedea pachetul de unde centrat aici pe
site-urile desemnate să ruleze acest experiment, unde culoarea corespunde condensatului chiral,
partea stângă arată rezultatele fără erori de la simulator, în timp ce partea dreaptă arată rezultatele de la calculatorul cuantic IBM
Torino, în mod ideal acestea ar fi imagini în oglindă una față de cealaltă din cauza simetriei, deci poți vedea că există
câteva imperfecțiuni, acum această axă verticală y corespunde bucăților de timp pe care le-am
măsurat anterior, deci de ce nu facem câteva secțiuni orizontale prin primul și ultimul pas de timp al datelor pentru a vedea
ce se întâmplă cu pachetul de unde la momentul t egal cu 1, aici în portocaliu, corespunzând
acestei secțiuni, poți vedea că condensatul chiral este îngust și localizat, de asemenea corespunde foarte bine
simulării realizate pentru comparație, la t egal cu 14 însă este mult mai răspândit și este mai puțin
localizat, poate că comparația cu simulatorul nu este chiar la fel de perfectă acum, dar poți vedea în continuare în mod evident un acord foarte bun între teorie și date
ceea ce este încurajator, în concluzie acesta este un exemplu foarte interesant al tipului de lucrare de simulare la care nu te-ai gândi inițial
să aplici calculatoare cuantice, totuși de fapt poți și funcționează, nu este perfect, dar nu trebuie să fii un
expert în fizica particulelor pentru a vedea că calculatorul cuantic prezice cu acuratețe propagarea spre exterior a pachetului de unde
ceea ce este exact ceea ce ne-am fi așteptat să găsim, sperăm că lucrările viitoare în acest domeniu vor continua și că fizicienii energiilor înalte
vor continua să găsească modalități de a încorpora Quantum Computing în fluxurile lor de lucru, scopul este să rezolve probleme teoretice mai precis și
pe cele care nu pot fi realizate clasic și să folosească experimente pentru a accepta sau respinge teorii în speranța descoperirii de noi
fizici, construind detectoare îmbunătățite și ducând la o mai bună înțelegere a naturii la nivelul ei cel mai fundamental
următorul nostru exemplu se concentrează pe optimizare și va fi o analiză aprofundată a unei lucrări numite biased field
digitized counter adiabatic Quantum optimization, realizată de membrii echipei kipu quantum din
Universitatea țării bascilor din Spania, vom începe ca înainte
cu o serie de definiții, prima este contra-adiabatica, care este un tip de evoluție care suprimă efectele non-adiabatice
experimentate de un sistem indiferent de cât de repede se produc acele procese, amintește-ți teorema adiabatica din
ultimul episod, de obicei trebuie să lași un sistem să evolueze foarte lent dacă dorești ca acesta să rămână în starea fundamentală
aceasta este o problemă mare deoarece cu cât trebuie să lăsăm lucrurile să evolueze mai lent, cu atât avem mai mult timp pentru ca erorile să
apară, conducerea contra-adiabatica adesea abreviată ca CD urmărește să combată aceasta prin
adăugarea de termeni care contracarează aceste excitații nedorite, ideea principală este de a accelera întregul experiment și
a reduce adâncimea circuit-ului cuantic prin suprimarea excitațiilor care ar putea duce la tranziții
spurii, acum să vorbim despre ce este un câmp de polarizare, alți algoritmi iterativi precum vqe iau parametri clasici în
aceste stări și folosesc optimizatori clasici pentru a căuta în spațiul multidimensional al parametrilor pentru acel set
care produce o valoare de așteptare minimă pentru un hamiltonian fix, în acest caz ei variază în schimb hamiltonianul la fiecare
WEBVTT
trecere, deplasând adiabatic de la un caz cunoscut la cazul de interes, dar deoarece nu sunt transmiși parametri clasici
și nu există o funcție de undă variațională, cum îți actualizezi starea de la o trecere a hamiltonianului la următoarea? ei bine,
adaugă un câmp de polarizare hamiltonianului, indiferent care este starea de energie minimă din rularea anterioară, adaugă un termen în
hamiltonian pentru a polariza starea în favoarea aceleia, deci de ce este de interes acest experiment?
ei bine, în primul rând aceasta este o nouă abordare care ar putea fi aplicată mai general altor probleme de optimizare
dar în acest caz au aplicat-o unei probleme a sticlei de spin Ising, după cum am discutat anterior, multe probleme de optimizare combinatorială
pot fi reformulate ca rezolvarea stărilor de energie joasă ale hamiltonienilor Ising, modelul
Ising este o serie de spinuri microscopice distribuite pe o rețea, modelul poate fi folosit pentru a descrie o sticlă de spin în care
magnetizarea este dezordonată, practic momentele magnetice mici sunt orientate aleatoriu în rețea și
de ce am crezut că va funcționa? ei bine, am acoperit deja cumva cum combatăm două probleme tipice găsite în
algoritmii variationali când am acoperit definițiile lucrării, dar pentru a rezuma, algoritmul pe care îl
propun accelerează evoluția pentru a reduce adâncimea circuit-ului, suprimând în același timp tranzițiile non-adiabatice
în plus nu se bazează pe nicio rutină clasică de optimizare, care poate fi o problemă ducând la platouri
aride și blocarea la minime locale, în ultimul rând autorii se asigură de asemenea să alinieze interacțiunile din problema
hamiltonianului cu conectivitatea hardware în qpu-ul real, ceea ce este întotdeauna foarte important, în ultimul rând, cum funcționează asta?
după cum am spus, nu se folosesc optimizatori clasici aici, cum se întâmplă adesea în algoritmii cuantici iterativi
în schimb, prin alimentarea soluției din fiecare iterație la intrarea pentru următoarea, algoritmul de optimizare cuantică digitizată
cu câmp de polarizare rafinează incremental starea fundamentală, aducând-o tot mai aproape de
starea finală evoluată, și combinat cu protocoalele contra-adiabatica putem face asta chiar și cu circuit-uri cuantice cu adâncime mică
care ar trebui să ruleze fără probleme pe hardware cu zgomot, deci când a fost realizat experimentul, autorii au ales să ruleze
algoritmul pe calculatorul cuantic IBM de 127 qubiți Brisbane, aici autorul a arătat
optimizarea algoritmului de optimizare pentru o instanță de sticlă de spin generată aleatoriu cu vecini apropiați
pe mai mult de 100 qubiți, compară rezultatele ideale de simulare ale dcq și bf dcq
precum și rezultatul experimental și arată de asemenea un rezultat de la un solver clasic numit goobi ca referință, acum
cu doar 10 iterații BF dcq oferă o îmbunătățire drastică comparativ cu
dcq, deși rezultatul experimental este puțin diferit față de rezultatul ideal din cauza zgomotului, performanța este în continuare
mai bună decât dcq ideal, aceasta arată că există în continuare mult progres excelent realizat în ceea ce
privește optimizarea Quantum și rezultate bune sunt raportate pe mai mult de 100 qubiți pentru una dintre primele
ori, nu în ultimul rând, este o lucrare foarte interesantă care explorează predicția structurii mRNA de la prietenii noștri de la
Moderna Pharmaceuticals și se numește mRNA secondary structure prediction using utility scale quantum
computers, pentru a începe, dacă ești ca mine și tot nu ai urmat un curs de biologie de câțiva ani, te poți împrospăta cu privire la ce
este mRNA, RNA mesager este un tip de RNA implicat în sinteza proteinelor
în esență citește instrucțiunile date de ADN, structura secundară a mRNA este mai mult sau mai puțin cum este pliat lanțul și
problema predicției structurii secundare a RNA este problema de a găsi plierea cea mai stabilă a secvenței
de baze ale nucleotidelor care alcătuiesc ADN și ARN, adică c, g, u și a, această
imagine arată unele dintre structurile de pliere comune găsite în mRNA, fiecare culoare evidențiată arată o
structură secundară diferită, dar caracteristicile exacte pentru ceea ce face una dintre aceste structuri mai favorabilă față de
alta nu sunt bine înțelese, tot ce putem face este să aflăm care dintre ele are energia liberă cea mai mică comparativ cu
starea nepliată, și acolo intervin calculatoarele cuantice, deci de ce sunt importante structurile secundare ale mRNA?
ei bine, predicția lor precisă este de fapt crucială nu doar pentru înțelegerea ADN-ului și a genelor noastre, ci și
pentru proiectarea terapeuticelor bazate pe RNA, cum ar fi vaccinul covid-19, există motive să crezi că abordarea din
această lucrare ar funcționa deoarece aceasta este de mult timp o problemă de optimizare formidabilă pentru
calculatoarele clasice din cauza vastului număr de configurații posibile și pentru unele configurații este de fapt cunoscut că este o
problemă NP completă, totuși pe un calculator cuantic putem formula predicția structurii secundare ca o
problemă de optimizare binară, ceva ce știm cum să gestionăm, în plus a existat deja dovezi în literatura de specialitate
de predicție precisă a ARN pe dispozitive cuantice la scară mică și pe simulatoare cuantice, deci întrebarea evidentă este
ar funcționa asta pe hardware mai mare? experimentul este realizat folosind ceva numit conditional value
at risk variational Quantum eigensolver, care este o modificare a algoritmului vqe tradițional și este
așteptat să atingă o mai bună convergență, această grafică arată distribuția probabilităților de măsurare
ale șirurilor de biți eșantionate cu energiile corespunzătoare pentru 42
nucleotide, instanța de 80 qubiți, aici șirurile de biți simbolizează perechi ale
nucleotidelor, ilustrează că șirul de biți cu cea mai mică energie are o valoare de energie de minus 140, care se potrivește cu cea mai mică
energie găsită de solverul clasic comparativ, deci asta e grozav și aceasta este structura pliată optimă
a acelui lanț de nucleotide bazată pe șirul de biți cu cea mai mică energie pe care hardware-ul
l-a găsit, și cu aceasta am ajuns la concluzia acestui episod, scopul meu nu a fost să te copleșesc cu
WEBVTT
detalii din diferite lucrări de cercetare, cum am spus, am vrut pur și simplu să îți dau suficient context pentru a înțelege cum
arată lucrările de ultimă oră în domeniu chiar acum, speranța este că aceasta va pune unele roți în mișcare în
mintea tuturor și că, văzând cum alții abordează problemele, vei putea face conexiuni și vei avea
încrederea să încerci noi experimente Quantum pe care poate nu le-ai fi încercat înainte, și hei, poate unele dintre ele nu vor
da roade și este bine, de aceea aceasta este cercetare, mergi mai departe amintindu-ți că tipurile de probleme care ne
interesează pot fi grupate fie după metodologie, fie după subiect și am prezentat pe cele pe care le considerăm a fi
cele mai promițătoare pe termen scurt, amintește-ți că Quantum Computing nu este bun pentru orice și de fapt aceasta este doar o
dovadă a cât de buni am devenit la calculul clasic, doar pentru că crezi că ai putea aplica Quantum Computing
la o problemă nu înseamnă că va produce rezultate interesante, din păcate trebuie să iei în considerare scalarea, adâncimea circuit-ului
este o sabie cu două tăișuri, trebuie să fie considerabil de mare pentru a face lucrări interesante pe care calculatoarele clasice
nu le pot face, dar chiar acum din cauza zgomotului hardware-ului nu o putem împinge la dimensiuni mari deoarece fidelitatea va
scădea, totul ține de găsirea acelui punct optim și de a ști că este o țintă în mișcare, deci ia ceva timp
între acum și episodul următor pentru a te gândi cu adevărat la câteva probleme pe care le-ai întâlnit și cum ai putea dori să le abordezi cu ceea ce am
învățat până în acest punct, fii creativ și nu te limita și dacă ai vreo idee chiar dacă crezi că este un pic
nebunească, anunță-mă în comentariile de mai jos, mulțumesc că ai urmărit și te văd data viitoare